hi i'm anthony fisher for recent TV and
I'm here with Jessica blank and Eric
Jensen the authors of the play The
Exonerated which is currently being
staged at the culture project in
Manhattan thanks for joining us thanks
for having me it's been ten years since
the first staging of the play and
there's been a TV movie produced what do
you think the cultural impact of the
play has been we're both actors but we
were both interested in documentary
theatre and we got the idea to travel
around the country interview exonerated
death row inmates and make a documentary
play out of the transcripts and we first
started working on the play
the idea of wrongful conviction and the
fact that it happens was just entering
the zeitgeist for the first time and
also the death penalty was in the news
because George Bush was running for
president for the first time and had
overseen more executions under his watch
as governor than all of the other
governors in all of the states in the
United States combined since the
reinstatement of the death penalty in
the early 70s it was actually just the
beginning of a national conversation
about the issue and the play incredibly
became a part of that conversation it
was performed for governor Ryan in
Illinois right before he left office as
part of his decision-making process
about whether who's gonna commute the
sentences of everyone on death row to
life in prison it's recently been
reported that exonerees receive almost
no support from the state after being
released which is in stark contrast to
people who have actually committed the
crimes they've served time for now
you've really done your research how was
the experience for some of the people
that had depicted in your play upon
being released it depends on case to
case you know some people even after
they were exonerated there's still a
stigma that hangs over down and people
are uninformed or uneducated about the
case or the issue or only have a
tangential idea what actually went on
there's a suspicion that hangs over them
and of all the things that are traumatic
when you get out that's probably one of
the most traumatic that's particularly
distinct in small towns we found when we
were doing our research and interviewing
people people who were convicted within
a small community and then went back
into that community upon their release
because that's where their family was
and that's where their support network
was I think some those people are some
of the folks
struggle the most because there's just a
level of suspicion that never goes away
and everybody knows each other and
people you know and actually it's
interesting in in the african-american
community it's sort of an open arm
situation people are really welcome back
in in the Caucasian community not so
much because I don't think wrongful
conviction is a daily part of life in
that community can you talk a little bit
about what the specific involvement of
the Innocence Project is with the play
oh my god the Innocence Project have
been incredible supporters of the play
almost since the very beginning they put
us in touch with several exonerees and a
portion of the proceeds from the box
office goes to support them because we
want to give back with this work they've
given so much to us and they do such
extraordinary work for the wrongfully
convicted this play is neither left-wing
nor right-wing all right we don't have
an agenda our job is to stay out of the
way and let just let the people tell
their stories for themselves really so
anyway when the pro death penalty attack
machine sort of came after us the
Innocence Project was right there coming
to our defense and walking us through
how to deal with stuff like that they
deal with that on a daily basis people
are trying to suck you into an
ideological debate here you're actually
just talking about the facts here's how
you get the conversation back on track
which was extraordinarily valuable
because that's what we're trying to do
here is keep the keep the conversation
on track about look this happens and it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if
you're the right set of things or if
you're Pro you're anti nobody's right
nobody wants innocent people to be put
to death that's right we have the
extraordinary gift in this country of a
constitution that lays out a criminal
justice system that if it were to
operate the way it's laid out on paper
would be extraordinary unfortunately a
lot of Americans don't know there is in
many cases a vast gap between how it's
meant to operate and how it actually
does because of human error because of
systemic flaws we all probably can get
on the same page no matter what our
political orientation about the fact
that it's important to close that gap
and get things working the way they're
supposed to according to the blueprint
that we have
thanks so much Jessica blank and Eric
Jensen authors of The Exonerated which
is currently being staged at the culture
project in Manhattan for recent TV I'm
Anthony Fischer